they reported a story about a US
ambassador early this morning that turns
out to be totally false the New York
Times hip piece indicated that nikki
Haley had spent nearly fifty three
thousand dollars indicated on curtains
in her residence in New York except
guess what
it wasn't trumped State Department it
was Obama's so The Times is now walking
back that story I like if you're gonna
do a hit job
don't fall flat on your face my friends
joining me now with reaction is Howie
Kurtz the host of media buzz which airs
Sundays here on FNC Howie how are you a
big news night for a Friday night and I
we have to hit this nikki Haley thing
further because this seems reminiscent
of what the Ben Carson
spending too much money and scott pruett
flying around on jet and now it's nikki
Haley something didn't just it didn't
ring true to me when I heard it what
really happened one of the worst
headlines I have ever seen in the New
York Times or any other newspaper trying
to paint nikki Haley some kind of out of
control scott pruett spending tens of
thousands of dollars on unnecessary
luxuries except when you read down to
the fourth paragraph for the story it
says that she had nothing to do with
this purchase of these fifty thousand
dollar curtains it was the Obama State
Department as you say and the editors
note says well gee we created unfair
impression and we should not have
focused on nikki Haley what was missing
is two things one is the story should
have been obliterated blowing up
digitally a race because it has no
longer has any reason to be and there
should be an apology from the paper to
nikki Haley yeah I mean I saw that there
was an editor's now who reads an
editor's knows that's like way down at
the bottom of the story I mean is it is
is that that's it they're able to do
that at the New York Times I sale her
character which essentially is what it
was and then add a little blip at the
end well at least there was some
acknowledgment of all the criticism with
the editor so I just don't think the
editors note went far enough not only
was it a bad headline when when you say
that it was unfair to frame this as a
nikki Haley expenditure then the story
simply has no way they should be
publishing above the fold in tomorrow's
paper a print edition if they want to
gain a shred of credibility back because
the New York slimes I'm sorry it's what
they are now is proving themselves to be
an
extension of the DNC that's all it is
DNC Obama Hillary whatever it is but
it's it the old gray lady is is you know
it should be red red faced with shame
after just that one piece I got to ask
you about this Ronan Farrow getting this
memo though today and again it's the
same letter that Dianne Feinstein gets
he gets it then he goes on TV and starts
talking about it well yes II want to
peel it surprise he has he has a lot of
credibility in reporting these issues
obviously Weinstein what NBC did to stop
that story and other cases like it but I
was kind of surprised that he decided to
kind of like go on television and talk
about this given how thin and how old
and how uncorroborated this particular
allegation is yeah well before Ronan
Farrow did that today I think most of
the media were sort of cautious about
what had all the earmarks of a late hit
I mean mysterious letter anonymous
accuser about something that may
allegedly have happened when Brett
Kavanaugh was 17 years old but Ronan
Farrow because of his credibility in
reporting on Harvey Weinstein unless
Moonves sort of gave the rest of the
media covered and now go on TV and yeah
got heated he did not interview this
woman he got a hold of the memo and you
know I admire his reporting but I think
it's fair to point out that he worked
for the Obama State Department I again I
will say what he did on the other
stories that's called shoe-leather
reporting this is taking a little gift
wrapped up from Diane Feinstein and
going on television say okay everybody
else you're clear you have covered to go
off and talk about this as if it's some
is something that happened you know five
years ago in his in his office over
there at the DC Circuit I am I'm telling
you this is an insult to real assault
cases and real sexual harassment women
who've been victimized should see this
for what it is a pure political attack
late hit on a great man I really
appreciate your job go ahead last word I
mean we just don't know the details
because the accuser is anonymous and
unlike Anita Hill at least testified and
was cross-examined the media need to be
extraordinarily careful Laura but not
being used in an 11th hour smear
I appreciate it Howie Kurtz